*multiple dabs*
[Best video title ever]
A$$ is OUT!!!!!!!!!!
Ass is out everywhere on every single console ever,
what are you doing?
What are you literally doing,
check out link in description. Download ASS now.
Finally ass is out. In case you don't know it's a game that I helped make
together with Armin and the great team of DOUBLE MOOSE.
NiCe JoB tEaM
For real,
we hope to make more games in the future.
For now, the game is out everywhere.
Check it out, support it.
Let's do community ones cuz they're always the most fun.
Let's sort by most likes
my has most likes!
Ah, that's cute.
Okay, let's do wipeout 1,0.
Oh, okay
Obviously I played wipeout so it's not up
obvious
obviously since I
Helped make this game that means I'm a pro at the game and
I know how to play every single aspect of it
Not a problem way too easy.
Oh my god.
I told you I'm a pro. Okay. Don't worry about it
As you can see the game has no glitches in it either which is why
God dammit. come on. Come on Rudy
We're fine. We're fine game of the year. Sorry game of this ce-- God Oh shortcut cool
game of the century
everybody
What else are you going to do with your life. Ow.
If you buy this game right now you will
Also lose your virginity. There we go. Everybody that was alright Mun
No! Glad we don't have a toxic fanbase so the ink comes with a level editor it works for any letter any platform
So you can play any level at any platform. It's a super they spent a lot of time working on this level editor
It's very intuitive
It's very easy to use. Do make some levels for me to play. Fight robot pirate markiplier
That sounds just like what I want. Oh my god. It is markiplier
What do I do? Oh my god. Jesus. okay.
Oh my god
Well props for being creative
damn
Wait, someone made a markiplier robot boss battle. Ok. That's awesome
Yeah, we got another attack, come on corndog damn it damn you markiplier
Seriously playing the levels that you guys make what's the right word? I'm
Flabbergast by you guys talent. This is like all you do is push shitty memes all the time
But here I can actually see that you have some talent which at least you know
I can I can appreciate you're not completely useless after all, you know what I mean?
There you go screw you markiplier! damn it
Notice how markiplier's beird doesn't connect fully I don't have that problem because I'm not a SOI boy
That play's in nintendo switch if you play this game on nintendo switch, you might as well
Just stop playing right away. Please do support this game on Nintendo switch. We spent a lot of money and time porting it to nintendo switch.
Am I selling the game enough for you? Come on, what is this a game made for soy boys get out of here too easy
There you go
Okay, we blew off his awkward beard now, we just gotta blow off his giant ego
I mean his face. Markiplier if you're watching just kidding JK. I love you
GOOOO! FUN! Go just go, just...
I'm alive. No, I'm not how am I not beating this stupid boss yet. Pathetic.
I take back every why does it fly off this game is garbage. I'm sorry. I'm just kidding. Please support this game, please
Okay, we got it. This is the bet. This is the best vehicle in the game guys. There you go
Look, this is the best vehicle in-- this game is fucking shit. This is the best vehicle in the game
Go go, I will kill you. There you go. Sometimes you just got to switch vehicles
There you go
All right. Well, we beat the level everybody. That's great! Felix recenserar din dod.
What it that basically means Felix is the best youtuber ever
in Swedenland. Alright, we got the helicopter. No problem. We're just got a respawn there. Oh, is that supposed to be me?
Is that supposed that's so offensive. God!
That doesn't even look like me.
Oh My god, I'm never getting I can't beat myself. Just kidding. I do that every day, haha
I
Missed me stupid pooter
I'm fine. How am I gonna fly enough? I can't fly enough fly
Corndog
Cool we beat another level guys that's really cool game of this century
Jacksepticeye's punch-out what? Oh my god. Wait, what is happening? Why what a good
Wait someone someone programmed punch-out.. what?
Sorry, oh my god, that is so crazy
How is that possible how?
how
Oh, I'm rolling to the sides. Oh my god. That is so creative.
screw you jacksepticeye
Damn it
Damn it.
Damn it. I've gotta beat jacksepticeye
What if I just spam? I'm just gonna spam it might work it might work. Damn it
Hit faster. Block ooh
Been to three
Damn it. I hate you. I know your moves said Jack
Stop!!
*intense silence*
Easy
Screw you! Best game of the year best game of thousand 3000 BC caveman-style
dab
You got one more gameplay
Just play this game honestly, though so creative
We made a game work with just a level editor people making all these cool stuff already sewed
Oh, wait. Am I supposed to get up how.
I need to-- I need the ass experimental. Come on. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Hey, it's not just my game guys. Remember it's... dammit. All right, maybe the ASSR isn't that good
We should probably use the copter. It should be easy with the copter.
All right, maybe not
Ah get up get up get up get up fine
We're doing good, we're gucci. Just get up there. Nice nice saute.
Oh Wait, what do I gotta do? I gotta hit the button, right?
Got'em! You dead boy you dead as ass boy
Yeah
Heck yeah guys smash like right now if you like A$$ as well. Wretis well done making that level
Alright, I'm gonna play more of you guys levels. So do make some in the level editors
I can't wait to see what you guys are gonna make I'm
super
impressed what you've already created, so
awesome
See if you can beat my levels as well
Solid s yeah, see if you can beat my levels as well
And check out the game if you like A$$ as well. That's it for me for now
brofist